temps de tir rapide Je nomme le sport que tu
nommes la chèvre Prêts, allez-y, sûr tennis
Federer basket-ball Jordan
Football euh je vais y aller avec Maradona
ok
poker
Ivy cricket cricket Je ne suis pas le
cricket Je ne connais qu'une poignée de noms
donc je'  Je vais juste dire t voiture Golf Tiger Woods
échecs Magnus Carlson échecs
boxe il y a ce gars Matt
quelque chose je ne me souviens pas de son
nom de famille mais je vais juste lui dire Matt
Matt Thomas Matt Thomas ouais Matt Thomas
bien appeler favori
film une question possible je dirai
Goodwill Hunting émission de télévision préférée
euh Breaking Bat livre préféré
livre que j'ai jamais lu je dirai juste
Harry Potter la personne la plus célèbre que vous
étiez impatient de rencontrer euh Peter jusqu'à la dernière
application que vous avez utilisée sur votre
téléphone  euh
Boisson préférée de Yahoo Finance Je dirai un repas à Moscou
Ronaldo ou Messi Ville préférée de Messi dans laquelle
vous êtes déjà allé
euh Londres Ville préférée dans laquelle vous avez déjà
joué aux échecs
euh
Kota debout toute la nuit ou tôt pour vous lever Je suis un
caméléon Je  Je peux faire soit une
équipe sportive préférée qui pratique le baseball, le baseball, les
Yankees de New York, le basket-ball, le
football des Knicks de New York, les
Titans du Tennessee, d'accord, mon
musicien préféré, je vais juste y aller avec un ananas des Red Hot
Chili Peppers sur ta chemise ou
sur une pizza ananas sur ma chemise, bien
sûr.  qui aimerais-tu voir la
boîte d'échecs de l'un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde j'aimerais voir nepo nepo
j'aimerais le voir boîte d'échecs qui gagnerait
entre toi ou Magnus en boxe d'échecs euh
nous sommes un peu différents  cours donc je vais
dire Magnus juste parce qu'il est un
peu plus grand, probablement un peu
plus en forme